what makes you giggle
like in the most joyful of
ways the suffering of others I mean I
there are um YouTube videos of
uh like fat people falling down and
they're they're really funny there's two
kinds of people in this world those that
laugh at those videos and those that
don't no and those that are in them
uh um my friend Jesse just told me a
great Norm McDonald joke and this is a
good litmus test joke because he says a
certain group of people lose their minds
and a certain group of people just stare
at you and he goes this kind of and so
I'll tell you the joke this is Norm
magdonald guy walks into a bar and he
sees someone at the bar who has a big
pumpkin for a head and the guy's like
dude what happened to you goes g you
never believe this I got one of those
Genie lamps and this Genie he's like
well what happened he goes well the
first wish you know I wish for $100
million he's like yeah' you get he goes
yeah you he was in my bank account it
was fine he goes all right well the
second wish I wish to have sex with as
many beautiful women as I wanted he goes
did that happen goes yeah it was amazing
he goes then what well I wish for a
giant pumpkin
head yeah so there's a certain mindset
that will just be staring at the screen
MH and that is I mean there's so many
levels why that's funny at least to me
and and I I just love that kind of well
nor McDonald is like uh just I watch his
videos all the time he's he's a guy that
definitely makes me giggle and he's one
of the people that makes me giggle for
reasons I don't quite understand did you
ever see him with carrat toop on um con
O'Brien no of making fun of katop no he
this is probably the best talk show clip
of all time he's on with Courtney Thorn
Smith she was on Melrose Place and con
Bryan's the host and Courtney is talking
about how she's going to be an upcoming
movie with katop and Cen is like oh
what's he going to be called and she's
like doesn't have a title yet and Norman
goes oh I know what should be called box
office poison and they're all laughing
and she's like no no no like the working
title is chairman of the board and Conan
goes do something with that smartass and
Norman goes yeah board is spelled b o r
e d and they all just completely lost it
there's something about him with words
spoken out of his mouth with way he like
turns his head and looks at the camera I
think he is one of those rare
comedians who you really feel like he's
talking to you directly yeah he feels
like he's winking at you yeah in the
audience and he's like can you can you
believe I'm doing this like it's it's
like he almost he feels like he's I
don't want to say imposter but like he's
more a member of the audience than he is
a member of the people on the stage yeah
it feels like he's on our side whatever
whatever the hell our
means